so why am I here with a child's toy well
this child's toy when it was introduced
went from 70 million in sales to 350
million in sales in a year it's over 2
billion dollars of equity value from a
company because of one thing that they
were able to do and what was that
thing they figured out that they could
demonstrate value ahead of time for a
customer and so if we're trying to sell
products and services a big thing that
we can do to get more people to want to
buy is think how can we demonstrate the
product in advance and so for example a
long time ago people used to buy clothes
without trying them on and then one very
enterprising business owner was like I
will let people try them on the store
even though I now have to build changing
rooms and I have to risk theft but even
despite all those things they were able
to make more sales and now it's Common
Place figuring out ways that you can
allow people to at least experience the
concept of it even if it's just by
demonstrating another client's results
in front of them it makes it much more
real and then what happens is it
decreases the risk that they're not
going to get what they want with the
purchase